There are a lot of times when we want to build
a reverse index from a data set, to allow for some
faster searching. If you've ever read some sort of reference book,
you've probably used an index. So here's a book I like,
A Brief History of Time. And the subtitle is From the
Big Bang to Black Holes. So let's say I just want
to read about the big bang. Well, only thing I can
do is crawl through all of this text, and look for
the words big bang. But of course, I'm not going to
do that. Somebody's already gone through put in the work in
advance to create an index for me. So at the end
of the book. I can just go to the index, and
on the first page we have B, and I see big
bang. And these are all the pages where I can find
it. And of course you can do the same thing with
the web, except instead of numbers, we'd have links to web pages.
This is a common problem, and so there's a design pattern to
solve. Why don't you take a shot at building your own inverted index?